هذا المشهد كان مالوفا قبل ثلاث سنوات اما
اليوم فيثير الرعب في قلوب سكان بكين
مطاعم وخاليه مدارس وشركات مغلقه ومبنى
سكنيه معزوله بالكامل لايام بالاضافه الى
اغلاق العديد من الحدائق العامه والاماكن
السياحيه
والصلاه الرياضيه والحفلات الموسيقيه
السلطات الصينيه قررت تجديد قيود احتواء
فيروس كورونا عملا بسياسه صفر كوميدي
وصل عدد الاصابات الى 1500 حاله يوم
الثلاثاء وتوفي ثلاثه مسنين خلال نهايه
الاسبوع عدد ليس كبيرا بالنسبه لمجمل
السكان لكنه قياسي للعاصمه التي لم تكن
تسجل الا عشره اصابات يوميا كحد اقصى خلال
الاشهر الاخيره
اما على مستوى البلاد تعدد الاصابات تخطى
28000 اصابه جديده مقتربا من اعلى مستوى
اصابات يسجل في الصين منذ ظهور الوباء
قبل 10 ايام عاده للاغلاق الجزئي ولفرد
فحوص واسعه نطاق كما اغلقت عده احياء في
كوانزو جنوب البلاد وطلب من المدارس
الانتقال الى التعليم عن بعد ومن موظفيا
المكاتب العمل من المنازل